[Musique]
le cinquième grand fin décembre du
conseil départemental c'est
traditionnellement déroulée à Villers
afin de célébrer l'abolition de
l'esclavage un travail de mémoire très
important pour Cyril Melchior président
du Département
5ecembre c'est l'occasion pour nous à
nouveau bien évidemment de rappeler les
valeurs de liberté que nous toutes nous
défendent les valeurs de liberté
que nos ancêtres n'ont pas connu parce
qu'ils étaient souvent esclaves jusqu'en
1848 et grâce à l'abolition de
l'esclavage et bien avant de liberté à
souffler sur la société réunionnaise
mais il nous convient toujours de se
dire que tout cela reste fragile à
partir d'une période trouble d'une
période violente de l'esclavage la
société réunionnaise s'est construite
dans la paix aujourd'hui disons Leclerc
monde une société apaisée mais nous
avons un devoir de mémoire quoi que plus
jamais et bien la violence de
l'esclavage ne puisse être pratiqué bien
sûr ici à la Réunion mais partout dans
le monde
Jean-Marc Ayrault président de la
Fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavage
et ancien Premier ministre était présent
pour les festivités il souhaite que
l'histoire soit transmise dès le plus
jeune âge en 2001 a été voté une loi la
loi Taubira mais qui a été un acte
politique extrêmement important parce
que la France a reconnu sa
responsabilité dans la traite et
l'esclavage et a reconnu que c'était un
crime contre l'humanité mais il y a dans
cette loi il y a eu une obligation
d'enseigner cette histoire dans les
programmes scolaires donc c'est très
important que on continue à l'école à
enseigner cette histoire collège lycée
mais aussi l'école primaire
les festivités ont débuté à la chapelle
pointue avec la séquence symbolique de
l'enlèvement de leur chaîne aux esclaves
le cortège s'est ensuite rendu au camp
marron
[Musique]
depuis le mois d'octobre et ce pendant
un an vilaine fait l'objet de fouilles
archéologique les chercheurs ont d'ores
et déjà trouvé un chemin qui permettait
aux esclaves de venir travailler sur
l'habitation mais également un des
outils utilisés le tout premier
exemplaire retrouvé les fouilles menées
par l'INRA pour révélé un certain nombre
d'objets et parmi les objets qu'on a
retrouvés figure ce qu'on appelle un pic
un pic utilisé à l'époque par les
esclaves pour creuser les trous dans
lesquels il devait planter la canne et
c'est le premier objet de cette nature
que l'on trouve on avait une trace
archivistique documentaire de cet objet
et c'est vraiment la toute première fois
que l'on retrouve un exemplaire de cet
outil qui était utilisé par une grande
grande partie des esclaves qui
travaillaient sur l'habitation
la fête a battu son plein toute la
soirée s'est terminée par un cabar
connecté
[Musique]